the royal family is still feeling the
effects of oprah's interview with prince
harry and meghan markle
one of the biggest bombshells was an
allegation that the royal family is
racist
in response prince william claimed that
the royal family is quote
very much not a racist family
now a lot of people are still skeptical
of that statement
but there is one person doing the media
rounds to back up prince william
we have him here tonight please welcome
sir john
kensington thank you so much
conan as the royal family's only black
friend i am
very grateful for this opportunity to
defend them against these
absurd accusations of racism okay well
this is interesting you definitely think
the royal family is not racist
i definitely know they're not conan
why else would they want to spend a
bunch of time with me
letting photographers take our picture
together all over london last weekend
okay i'm sorry you didn't find it
suspicious that they wanted to be seen
publicly with you
immediately after oprah's interview with
harry and megan
it wasn't immediately after conan it was
the next day
prince william called me up and asked me
to remind him of my
name and after i explained to him i
don't know
charles barkley he signed and said
well come over i guess and poof
i'm at buckingham palace okay well
that's
interesting and they they treat you like
one of their friends
oh undoubtedly we've become
so close that they have royal guards
follow me everywhere i
go throughout the palace
i'm sorry that actually doesn't sound
that friendly
uh however do you mean okay it's a
little awkward for me as a
white guy to be explaining this to you
it just sort of sounds like they're
trying to make sure you don't steal
something
oh piss pause conan how can i steal
something if i'm not even allowed to
touch anything okay well i'm sorry that
sounds
racist oh sure
it's racist conan yes everything's
racist
now how can you be the one to tell
me what racism is i suppose it's
racist whatever prince charles asks me
to rap for him
well kind of yeah yeah oh or how about
when they tell me their favorite actress
is
one half of rasheeda jones you know i'm
just guessing that
no that definitely sounds bad that is
nice the royal family is so
not racist how not racist
are they the queen elizabeth
knighted me why she knight i guess
that's pretty
significant and now whenever she sees me
she says now that i've knighted you
you've got to let me
say it and i say of course you can tell
people that united me
and she goes no i don't want to say that
word i want to say the other word
you know the word that you all get to
say together to each other
that that word that you know everyone
know
of your oh my god
they are racist yeah i'm sorry
hello william yes
no i'm not charles barkley no no no more
raps
all right i'm sorry i'm very sorry sir
john kensington everybody
i'm so sorry he's big boxing he's what
he's beat boxing beatbox he's beatboxing
he's really good actually oh he's good
oh he's oh
well really good okay well anyway i
still think it's inappropriate for him
to be beat boxing to you
i'm sure you'll straighten it out